people in Charlottesville this morning
have come together last night to take a
stand against white supremacists it was
one of several vigils across the country
the show of solidarity followed a
weekend of violence in Charlottesville
that killed one woman and hurt dozens 32
year-old Heather hire died when a car
drove into counter protesters after a
demonstration by neo-nazis white
supremacist and Klu Klux Klan members
newly released video shows the graphic
violence of the alleged attack the Dodge
Challenger sent protesters flying as it
slammed into the crowd and hit another
vehicle cars owner James Alex Fields jr.
is charged with second degree murder
David beg know is in Charlottesville
where he spoke to victims and - Heather
hires friends David good morning Jeff
good morning this memorial is the spot
where that driver crashed into the crowd
of people that had been told to go home
and we're doing so that man came
barreling down this one-way street and
hit those people the police say it was
intentional one man was seen flying into
the air in a now viral photo we found
that man in a wheelchair here at a vigil
in this exact spot last night to stand
up for what I believe to do acknowledge
what's right what's right and what's
wrong was wrong Marcus Martin insists
that the counter protest on Saturday was
peaceful his fiance Marissa Blair even
broadcast it live on Facebook but then
chaos that is when an alleged white
supremacist apparently drove his Dodge
Challenger into a crowd of protesters
this photo captures the moment Martin is
hit by the car over he broke his leg and
will need surgery
that is his red shoe flying out from
underneath the suspects vehicle as he
reversed away his fiancee escaped injury
because Martin pushed her away how can
someone have so much hate in their heart
Heather hire who was killed was their
friend Blair worked with her at a
Charlottesville law firm she died for
peace she died for equality she died
because she believed that everyone
should get along
Heather hires friends honored her by
wearing purple shirts that had a quote
from her last public Facebook post if
you're not outraged you're not paying
attention even after police told
demonstrators to leave men waited
Confederate and neo-nazi flags and armed
with shields and clubs clashed with
angry counter protesters Jason Kessler
who organized the unite the right rally
said police didn't protect their First
Amendment rights and he blamed the
police for the violence Kessler had a
press conference Sunday that ended
suddenly he was swarmed at the podium
and punched he was also chased in a
nearby bushes where he was tackled by a
young woman forced to flee behind a
barricade of officers who were in
tactical gear later at a vigil for hire
Marcus Martin vowed to fight for justice
my mother can't talk to her daughter she
can't hug
I'm gonna has a barrier daughter Heather
didn't deserve this
how did I have standing in what she
believed in Jason Kessler had a permit
from the city of Charlottesville which
allowed him and his protesters to be
here this weekend legally now in
criticizing police the Charlottesville
police chief told CBS News wait a minute
I had officers and the help of the
National Guard and they moved in when
the time was right charlie mr. Kessler
was literally run out of downtown
yesterday by people who live here thanks
David